Do you think you could go a whole week
without producing any garbage?
It's a hard thing to do.
The average American produces around
4.5 pounds of trash each day.
Almost everything in our lives is
single-use or single-packaged: bags, straws, coffee cups. But it doesn't have to be
this way. This is Lauren singer and she
lives a zero-waste life.
"It wasn't like yesterday I made 4.5 pounds of trash and today makes
zero it was a gradual step-by-step thing."
Lauren has cut out all the stuff that
you can't easily compost, reuse or
recycle. And see this little mason jar
inside is all of the trash she's made in
the past four years.
The U.S. is the number-one trash
producing country in the world.
This means that four percent of the
world's population is responsible for
nearly twenty percent of the world's
waste. So we said M. Sanjayan, a UCLA
visiting researcher and the head of
Conservation International, to meet with
Lauren. "You would, like, freak out if you,
like, saw my life. I mean you really would."
"I was an average consumer four years ago."
"No, no... you would be freaking out." The two of them
compared their toiletry kits... "What is all this?"
...to see if there are some simple
ways that Sanjayan could reduce his trash
impact. "I don't even know what's in here,
now I'm like, 'Oh my god!'"
"Toothpaste."  "Toothpaste."
"But mine's got 'Sensi-relief."
"I don't even know what that means."
Lauren makes her own toothpaste and the
recipe is actually pretty easy. One
tablespoon of baking soda, two
tablespoons of coconut oil, 1/4 teaspoon
of stevia and then 15 to 20 drops of
peppermint oil. "If you wonder, you know
why is toothpaste peppermint-flavored
or cinnamon-flavored, it's not like
arbitrary, random. It's because peppermint
oil and cinnamon oil are really great
antimicrobial and antibacterial agents.
so this, actually, I'll just put some
peppermint oil in water and use it as a
mouthwash.
So you just stir everything together."
"This is crazy
it really is toothpaste?"  "Yeah."
"How different is this from what I buy in the tube?" "So this won't foam up, there's
no foaming agent. Most toothpastes will
use sodium lauryl sulfate." "And why do
they do that?" "So companies do that
because they're simple shortcuts and they
think that's what people want ,but they
dictate, kind of, what people want. So for
instance, this might taste salty to you..."
"No, actually it taste actually pretty good."
And it smells good, and it's easy, and it's a lot less expensive than
buying toothpaste. So like, I shave with
this so this is my razor and then the
blades are just stainless steel like super,
super recyclable, come packaged in paper. Easy."
'OK. That I've had for a long time. But  these do get replaced and they are expensive." "I can buy 100
blades for like $20 and that's enough
for the next ten years of my life. And like
four of those are $20." "Like I could do
this, but definitely when you travel
they're going to be all over you for the blade. I have a funny feeling TSA treats you
slightly differently than they treat me.
Can you imagine if I try to bring this on a plane?"
"But they're really easy to find in
any city at any like barber shop or
whatever. So actually baking soda works
really well as deodorant and sometimes
you can just use that, but this is a mix
of shea butter, coconut oil, baking soda,
arrowroot powder, and essential oils." "So
there's deodorant and there's
antiperspirant." "You should not make
yourself not sweat. It's how your body
eliminates toxins and cools itself
naturally." "Yeah but but isn't there a
practicality to this?" "Sweating can be
sexy." "I know, but you don't want, like
you can't sit on a plane with some
sweaty guy next to you. It's not going to be
sexy trust me. Like this is a genuine
challenge, right? So I don't like using
this stuff
partly because it's got aluminum as one
of the active ingredients."
"You definitely should not use that at all. You should probably change that real quick."
But there isn't anything?"
"Can you wear an undershirt?"
'OK..."
"But lots of men do that lots of women do
that."
"Yeah, yeah. I could."
"Did you make that or did you...?"
"My friend made it for me."
"OK."
"You use the same soap for as shampoo as well as soap?"
"Shampoo, soap, face wash."
"Isn't there
like a difference?"
"Nope...marketing. This is conditioner that I buy
in bulk."
"What's in conditioner?"
"Conditioner is essentially just like a
lotion, but you can use aloe vera or
coconut oil and it works just as well."
"So
of all these things that you've shown me,
the one that I'm really convinced about
and to be absolutely honest I would
probably incorporate into my own life
is the toothpaste. One, because that
tastes actually pretty good and it's easy."
There's definitely not a
one-size-fits-all way to reduce your
waste. "I think the best place to start is
just by looking at your trash and seeing
what you're already throwing away and
seeing if they're simple ways to
remediate those problems. If there's
something that you notice you're
throwing away a significant amount of,
it's as simple as doing a search on my
blog Trash as for Tossers, or a really
simple Google search asking, you know,
'What's the sustainable alternative to...'
There's also lots of one-time
changes that can be made that have a
large-scale and long-term positive
impact. So using reusable bags, Using
reusable coffee cups. So it's just
identifying what the problems are and
then finding simple sustainable
solutions to them." And the University of
California wants to make some of these
simple changes too. UC is committed to
going zero waste by 2020. Across the UC
system, we've already diverted 69 percent
of our solid waste from landfills. But
getting all the way to zero waste,
especially at this scale is a real
challenge. To learn more about UC's zero
waste initiative and how you can help,
visit zerowaste2020.universityofcalifornia.edu and be sure to check out
Lauren's blog trash is for tossers, which
has a bunch of great tips and tutorials
for reducing your waste impact